hello we begin with breaking news out of
Thailand where former prime minister
Texan shinawat has been sentenced to
eight years in prison now The Verdict by
the Supreme Court came just a few hours
after he returned to Thailand from
self-imposed Exile of 15 years he's been
taken to a Bangkok prison the jail terms
are related to three separate cases
including abuse of power these
developments came on a day the Thai
Parliament expected to vote on a
candidate put forward by his political
allies to form the new government now Al
jazeera's Tony Chang is joining us with
the very latest on the phone from
Bangkok Tony talk to us a little bit
about what we know about this judgment
that's just come down
I think it's an important distinction to
make this is not a judgment the Judgment
was made more than a decade ago while Mr
taxon was outside the country what
happened this morning was that he was
informed uh when he landed of that
judgment you know by the Supreme Court
they changed his identity this was
something that Mr tankson was very much
expecting and they have now taken him to
Bangkok Roman prison they say that the
sentence is eight years two of those
sentences will run concurrently slightly
less than the 10 years that we
understand had initially been he'd been
sentenced to nonetheless the big
question here is how much is he actually
going to serve there are many
possibilities there's a lot of
speculation in Thailand might he be
released on the grounds of ill health
might there be a royal pardon granted
and I think it's also very important to
remember that his political allies are
holding a vote this afternoon in
Parliament for a nomination to form a
government he could possibly have one of
his allies as the prime minister in
their new government his party per time
may be in charge of the Justice Ministry
so there's a lot potentially to play out
here but I think the fact that he has
decided to come back and face the music
after all of this time suggests that
he's at least prepared to spend one
night in jail I think many people would
be surprised if he's there for the full
eight years thank you for clarifying
that really important legal Nuance it is
it is a critical distinction okay help
us understand then all of this is
happening at the time of a crucial vote
in Parliament on who will be Thailand's
new prime minister help us understand
and explain that
well that is also something I think many
people here are watching very closely
and trying to work out the elections
happened four months ago the party that
won tried to get their man through uh as
the nominee for prime minister that
failed so the second party the one
Allied to Mr Texan has now got a new
Coalition uh they are putting their
nominee in front of parliament today a
man called seta kawisen they say they
had the support in the lower house for
him to get the backing he needs but the
big question is in the Senate the upper
house that is held this there are 250
seats held by military appointed
Senators that was where the last nominee
fell down we don't know at this stage
whether Mr Sita is gonna get the NOG
from the Senate he may do that may be
part of the deal that brought Mr Texan
back you know this stage I think
everyone is watching proceedings very
closely on television on tender hope
indeed all right Tony Chang joining us
on the phone from Bangkok with the
developments that continue to change by
the moment thank you for that okay we're
going to bring in praveat rojana Frick
he is a political analyst and calling us
at hasud English news website he joins
us from Bangkok as well help us
understand we know that this has been a
period of gridlock if in recent months
help us understand the legal issues here
given the fact that the timing the
return of tax in shinua is certainly no
coincidence
how does all of this play out the fact
that he now has had this sentence of
eight years his judgment though comes
some time ago what does all of this mean
well it means toxin is desperate uh
after a decade and a half being in Exile
we really want to return to home because
here he's not just another billionaire
here in Thailand he is tax in China what
the longest uh serving elected prime
minister of Thailand I mean former that
is
um and he's already 74. so the thing is
although he has just been sentenced to
eight years in prison for corruption
related cases uh once you're over the
age of 70s you could apply for some
leniencies he may be moved to the
corrections departments run hospital or
even a private hospitals in the days
ahead and certainly he is seeking the
Royal pardon from the Thai King sure on
top of that but just because you want to
be back in office I mean why today why
didn't he come two weeks ago certainly
today is signifi I mean Thailand's Pro
Cinema party has nominated srita tavisan
to become Prime Minister does that play
into all of this
oh absolutely
um it's because he is confident that uh
four hours or five hours from now today
uh Saint Thomas the SATA he putai
protection party PM candidate will
become Prime Minister elect uh they have
cracked a deal with the pro military
Junta political party which has a lot of
influence over the Junta appointed
Senators who will jointly vote in this
bicameral process this afternoon so
Texans believe uh by the end today uh
the a new governance will be elected and
that will be the government runs by a
party which is nominally under his
leadership
and could that government perhaps have a
decision on his eight-year sentence
well they can't do anything of course
they can make sure he stay comfortably
uh while inside prison in which he's
already inside Bangkok women in prison
as we speak but again as I said he could
cite ill health uh at all age to seek uh
leniencies and he could be moved to a
hospital or or or
infirmary facilities while awaiting a
possible Royal pardon to be granted
very interesting developments we
appreciate you joining us praveat rojana
Frick thank you for helping us
understand this fast-moving story
thanks for having me